What some people are concerned is that
this Leninist organization which is
looking at what's happened successfully
in El Salvador, in Nicaragua, in Venezuela,
where these revolutionary governments took power,
that they want to replicate that in Colombia.
The guerrillas negotiated such a generous package of
economic assistance, social support for
these areas of past conflict where
the guerrillas are actually be resettling.
It's such a generous package, as a matter of
fact, that the Colombian state doesn't
have the means to comply.
If the state doesn't comply with its commitments,
it's going to be subject to criticism.
So almost immediately the FARC will attack
the fact that the government's not
complying with its commitments
under the peace agreement.
The guerrillas could use that criticism and that's the concern.
Using the democratic means,
abusing representative democracy, and
then eventually taking power and
dissolving the institutions so that they
can hold power in perpetuity.
What do you think's in store for Colombia?
Let us know in the comments
section and let us know what other
topics you want AEI scholars to cover in 60 seconds.